Speaker 1: I want to talk about a
bit of news from a few days ago,
which is quite interesting. There is now a report
that President Joe Biden told former President
Barack Obama that he is going to run in 2024, that
Joe Biden will run for reelection in 2024. There
is a report in The Guardian from a few days ago
which has a subheadline. The president, Joe Biden,
thinks he's the only one who can beat Trump,
according to what a source told The Hill,
as Trump readies his own third run, the
article reads, Joe Biden has told Barack
Obama he will run for reelection in 2024,
according to the Washington website The Hill,
the site cited two anonymous sources. One
was quoted as saying Biden wants to run
and he's clearly letting everyone know. It
wasn't clear when Biden told Obama his plan,
but Obama did visit the White House earlier
this month to celebrate the Affordable Care Act.
We know that Joe Biden used to be the
vice president at 78. Biden was the oldest
president ever inaugurated. If he won again,
he would be 82 at the start of his second term.
In September. It was widely reported Biden
and aides told allies he planned to run again
in December. Biden said he would run if he stayed
in good health. He also said Kamala Harris as VP
would be on the ticket again. In a December
interview with ABC. Biden said another Trump
candidacy would increase the prospect of running
in Brussels in March. Biden referred to Trump
when he said In the next election, I'd be
very fortunate if I had the same man running
against me. Do I think Joe Biden is going to run
again? I actually don't know. I at this point.
I believe that Joe Biden has to say it is
my intention to run for reelection. I don't
have any doubt that that is the correct thing to
say. It would be problematic for his presidency
now to say I'm not even going to run again. It
would be a news cycle, a serious news cycle.
It would interfere with whatever it is Joe
Biden plans to try to do in what's left of
his first term. So I think that no matter what his
intentions are, this is what he would be saying
right now, whether he will ultimately run. I don't
know. Now, the question of who could beat Trump.
We actually do have some polling. And I know that
looking at polling this early is a bit fraught.
But we have a number of different polls which can
give us some information. Many of these are from
the last few days in a hypothetical Biden versus
Trump matchup. The Morning Consult Politico poll
has Biden 45 and Trump 44. Now, you could argue
that's not great because Trump isn't even really
a candidate. You could also say Trump really kind
of is a candidate because everybody thinks he's
running in an insider advantage. Poll a Trump is
defeating Biden. 4743. There is a YouGov Yahoo!
News poll where it's Biden 43, Trump 41. And then
there's also other polls like Bernie versus Trump,
where Trump bests Bernie by one in morning
consult. So I don't know that these polls at
this point, given that we don't know if Biden's
running and we don't know if Trump is running,
I don't know how much they tell us other than it's
not obvious anybody's going to run away with it. I
think that's the fair takeaway from what we have
from polling so far. If it's Biden versus Trump,
there is a fight and either candidate could win.
If it's not Trump and it's Kamala Harris, it's
conceivable that either one could win. If
it's not Trump or Biden, and instead it's,
for example, Harris DeSantis, as the Harris poll
asked. Right now it's Harris plus four. So I think
it's too early for any of these polls to tell us
anything definitive other than there's uncertainty
about who the candidates will be. And there's
a real question mark as to who voters would,
in theory, rally behind. I think that we just
don't know. What I want to hear from you is,
do you think Biden should run for
reelection? Let us know in a YouTube comment.
Find me on Twitter at the Pacman or on any of
our other platforms. Next week we'll do a kind of
reaction segment and see what folks are thinking.
The David Pakman Show depends on your support.
I would love for you to sign up at join pacman
dot com, get a membership, get the extra bonus
show every single day and get a commercial free
audio and video feed of the show every single
day, up to 6 hours before The Daily Show is
published. Join Packman dot com is the place
to sign up. You can use the coupon
code. Wow 22 for a discount.